this mascot is TCU mascot it's a frog
which is a horn frog I do not know what
a Christmas tree is Happy Christmas tree
I'm guessing it's the tree why are they
red the tree is green this looks like
California this master has got to be
California mascot this is Ohio State at
the Kool-Aid Man
boss is this Western Kentucky it is
Western Kentucky mascot this is Clemson
Tigers this Coastal Carolina what type
of bird is that I know it's bird it's
Nebraska what is he supposed to be
though Kirby the Husker Corn Husker so
what do you do
I was gonna say the same thing this is
Oregon Oregon Duck this is my mascot
Ralphie she's not a boy she's a bison
Dion I don't know I don't think he liked
it that much he's scared of this is
Michigan State Park I didn't know what
he's supposed to be this is Alabama it's
a elephant Roll Todd what is this this
is a tank I don't know what it's
supposed to be what magic card is this
that's keggy the cat from Dartmouth
that's what school
yeah I never heard of that school